Mẹ hai tháng 2, chính quyền tổng thống mấy đôn nân trong thông báo đảo vừa kết luận về mối mối huy hiệm.
Giờ các quan bảo vệ mua trường nĩ i phê bán hành năm 2018, không trong lệ chính,
giới thời cựu tổng thống bà rắc ở bà mạc.
Và bản khi đó sẽ định sáo rọi khi gây hiệu uống nhà kính,
chừng đầu có các bong điều si và mẹ tình là mối đi giòa đô bệnh suy khai cộng đồng.
Tất nhiên tảng pháp lý cho các quy định hạn chế khí thải,
đặc biệt là trong lĩnh vực bệnh sau thông.
Nhà chẳng gợp quy định mối là bất bại bỏ quy định lớn,
cho sang đậm thay này sử dụng bà dạm chí phi sà sudo tô,
và hạn giá thành trường người tư dụng.
Tâm thống đơn trong cổ nhận định các quy định chức đây,
đơi tổn hạn chương hành tông nghi bố tôn và đầy giá cả lým cao đối với người dân Mỹ.
Ở chương lực lại cụ tổng thống bà rắc ở bà mạc,
người hiếm khi đưa ra các biệt lạc.
Đã lým tính chương sang việc huy bỏ phán quyết,
có thể khiến nước Mỹ đối mặt mối dù gió lớn hơn,
bị sức khỏe và mối trường,
ông khẳng định đọng,
của đình chỉ tạo cơ hội trong hành công nghiệm như liệu hóa thạch kiếm được nhiều tiên hơn.
Một số tổ chương mối trường cũng tương bộ sự tiến hành các biển pháp pháp liếp,
nhằm phản đối quy định này.